vielen Dank dass Sie Zeit haben für uns
sehr gut das ist ihr Büro
[Musik]
das ist alles alle Bilder ausgeben
geile Bilder von unserer Stadt
das haben wir unsere alle denken
Denkmale geschützt
alle Gebäude
das unsere Stadt
ich glaube ganz schnell renoviert die
Gebäude waren es die ganze Konstruktion
können wir
[Musik]
das ist um mich und zurückzubringen in
weil dieser
und zurück zum seine Häuser
Feuerwehrfahrzeuge die kommen auch ein
Teil von Deutschland
[Musik]
auch Ambulanz
und
[Musik]
auch die medizinische Behandlung sehen
sie wie alle
Fenster ist mit Sandsäcke das ist
[Musik]
habe ich schon gesagt das ist fast
10.000 Kinder in dieses Jahr und alles
alles in
Katakomben unter die Erde am
eindrücklichsten in Erinnerung geblieben
was ist Ihnen ganz besonders in
Erinnerung geblieben wenn Sie
Börsen von Geschichten
einer davon
das war zweite Woche von einem Krieg die
oder erste Woche für den krieg ich die
unsere Hauptbahnhof war brechend voll
und haben wir kontrolliert und
war eine Ecke für Kinder und
kommen zum Kinder und eine junge circa
zu machen
ja gefallen macht keine sorgen für alles
wird dann an Papa Mama gefragt
und so weiter das kommt eine Frau sagt
ich bin Begleiterin
wie erlauben uns nicht dann Kinder zu
sagen wir wissen nicht wer soll das und
wie das müssen wir sagen das Kind ist
ohne Eltern gerne älter ist gestorben
und Junge hat
nie gewusst
Mama und Papa kommt nie wieder
fast ein Jahr Krieg in der Ukraine wie
sehr hat dieser Krieg auch Sie
persönlich verändert
von unserer Land verändert
jede Mensch diese Krieg in Ukraine
berührt nicht so eine auch in Europa das
ist eine riesige für unseres Land
das ist auch große Herausforderung für
ganze Europa für ganze moderne Welt und
die begreifen noch nicht aber das ist
auch eine riesige Tragödie für Russland
was betrifft Wirtschaft was betrifft die
ganze Land was betrifft das Leben von
von russische Bevölkerung
also eine Veränderung für die ganze Welt
und wenn sie jetzt sagen würden für sich
persönlich wie hält man das aus ein Jahr
voller Angst und Anspannung
Alarmbereitschaft sozusagen als
Dauerzustand
bekommen
[Musik]
ständig wir leben und die Risiko
zu sterben von Lüftung Briefe Raketen
Angriffe
und deswegen
ständig hören wir öfter waren
haben wir mehr als
650 mal Luft wenn man
zusammenbringt die ganze Zeit
mit Luft in letztes Jahr die jede Burger
von unserer Stadt hat mehr als ein Monat
unter der Erde verbracht in Brücke in
sichere Plätze und unsere U-Bahn unter
der Erde können Sie vorstellen jedes
eine Monat eine Monat von 12 die jeder
Bürger von unserer Stadt in
in Sicherheit und bunte verbracht
das betrifft auch wie
Leben von unserer wohl gefährdet
keine einfache keine einfache
Herausforderung aber wir leben wie schon
bereits Leben zu ohne Strom weil wir
haben noch Defizit von Strom die haben
sehr viele unsere
Energie Kraftwerk ist
beschädigt teilweise
was interessantes was von Sinn
von Russen das alles zu zerstören damals
Liebe zu stören von
Zivilbevölkerung
die versuchen ein depressive Laune an
Menschen zu bringen und
stattdepressive Laune
unsere Bevölkerung hat eine riesige Wut
und
sich mal mit Menschen gesprochen die hat
gesagt Liebe ohne Strom und Wasser als
mit russische Soldaten
für überleben wir kämpfen für eine
demokratische europäische Zukunft und
wir wollen auf keinen Fall wieder in
russische Diktatur zurückzukommen also
diese Zermürbungstaktik geht nicht auf
der Russen nein das funktioniert nicht
vor einem Jahr gab es viele
Militärexperten die gesagt haben die
Ukraine hat keine Chance gegen die
russische Übermacht warum ist das anders
gekommen
sehr viele Experten in der Welt hat uns
paar Tage oder paar Wochen gegeben weil
Russland hat eine die größten und
stärkste Armee in der Welt der Russland
ist großmächtig stark aber in dieses
Jahr haben wir Mythos über die stärkste
russische Armee
unsere Soldaten ich kann ich habe
hier Erklärung
russland hat mehr Panzer mehr Flugzeuge
mehr Ausrüstung aber die wichtigste in
eine Gegenstand
ein Wien zum Sieg
die innere Kräfte
ist kein Geheimnis russische Armee gut
bezahlt
unsere Soldaten kämpfen
für Überleben kämpfen für unsere Familie
und verteidigen unsere Kinder beteiligen
unsere Zukunft und das ist die Frage die
klare klare Regeln in der Krieg Menschen
sterben
die Frage die sind bereit für das Geld
zu sterben und wie viel kostet der Iris
leben
von Menschen und bezahlbar
aber wenn die Frage kommt
um eure Familie und Kinder
jede ohne nachzudenken
die ist bereit
wenn nötig ist zu sterben zu seiner
Kinder für seine Familie das ist
Unterschied zwischen ukrainische
Soldaten und
Russland wieso wir sind so stark so darf
unsere Soldaten beteiligen unseres Land
und wo wenn noch zusätzlich
bekommen wir auch moderne Waffen
Verteidigungswaffen weil sehr viele
Diskussionen in Europa gewesen sollen
wir noch keine Waffen zu liefern
wir brauchen Verteidigungswaffen weil
wir verteidigen unseres Land auch eine
war immer eine friedliches Land wo leben
finde Menschen
seit 30 Jahren Abhängigkeit wir waren
niemals aggressiv gegen andere Länder
aber heute
wir haben keine andere Wahl wir müssen
verteidigen und unseres Land unsere
Sanität unsere digitalen Integrität und
wir wollen auf keinen Fall
leben in einem Land wo es gibt keinen
Menschenrechte wo ist kein gibt keine
demokratische Werte und deswegen wir
kämpfen heute um unsere europäische
Zukunft weil unsere Wunsch unsere Traum
ein Teil von europäische Familie zu
werden wir wollen nicht zurück zum zu
werden Union die war dort und wir haben
dort gar nichts zu suchen wir sehen
unsere Zukunft
Anteil von europäische Familie
von tanzen geredet Deutschland hat lange
gezögert Kampfpanzer wie die Leopard zu
schicken jetzt gibt es sie
können Sie Menschen verstehen die sagen
es braucht nicht mehr Panzer sondern
mehr Bemühungen und friedenslösungen
jede in Deutschland wäre denkt sollen
wir Waffen zu liefern oder nicht so weit
ziemlich große Diskussionen in
Deutschland ich möchte eine sagen wir
haben alle eine riesige Fehler gemacht
ich habe ihn gedacht putin wird
glücklich mit Annexion
danach alle hat gesagt er wird glücklich
mit Benetzung ganz ehrlich nie glücklich
er brauchte ganz hoch keine und Putin
für präsentieren sich selbst als
diejenige als Sammler die jemalige
russische Territorium und ihr deutsche
mussen nicht vergessen eine große Teil
von Deutschland auch war ein Teil vorbei
an von sowjetische Imperia wo Putin als
Kind Jahre lang gearbeitet hat und
deswegen ähm wir kämpfen und verteidigen
nicht nur unsere Familie und wie
verteidigen hier von euch weil
wir sehen der aggressiver Politik von
Russland die gehen so weit wie weit wir
glauben zu gehen
die Clown deutlich sprechen wir zum
krämerle über Poland über baltische
Länder wo wir wieder aufbauen des
sowjetischen macht russische macht
gemeinsam mit diesen stark und gemeinsam
wir müssen Werte
europäische Werte verteidigen und ich
bin mehr als überzeugt die jeden Europa
hat einen Wunsch und wir sind auch keine
schnell wie möglich Frieden
zurückzubringen und es klingt
wahrscheinlich
interessant aber wie Stärke wir sind wie
mehr Waffen bekommt keine wie Stärke
werden desto schneller Frieden konnte
unseres Land weil wir greifen keine wie
verteidigen uns wir brauchen nicht noch
die Betonung Beteiligung zu machen und
wir möchten wir bedanken an unsere
Freunde
gibt uns die Mittel
uns und euch auch zu verteidigen das ist
unwichtig heute für die ganze Welt
wie sehen sie die Rolle Deutschlands in
dem Krieg durch und deine die
wichtigste Land in Europa
Deutschland
hat immer Funktion als
Lokomotive zu werden in
Weltwirtschaft
von Deutschland sehr viel und äh bitte
nicht vergessen noch eine der größte
Land Europas und äh
die Stabilität und noch eine kann die
Stabilität die ganze Regionen ganz
Europa zu bringen deswegen wir brauchen
und jede von europäische Länder
sind interessiert
die Frieden schnell wie möglich noch
keine zu bringen
zu sehen
und Deutschland eine die größte Geld
gäbe immer war für durch eine
Deutschlands war sehr wichtige Partner
für Deutschland und Deutschland für
Türkei eine und
ich fühle mich nicht Fremden in
Deutschland und Deutschland nicht
fremdes Land für mich und deswegen ich
trage gerne funktionieren sogenannte
Brücke zwischen Deutschland sucht eine
und Deutschland seine gute Beispiele
als moderne demokratische Land und wir
wollen genau das gleiche Land bei uns
machen
die Korruptionsaffären ist das eine der
Schwachstellen der Ukraine noch
wir müssen sehr viele entsprechende
europäische Zukunft wir müssen sehr
viele sehr viele Reformen machen was
betrifft das unterelisierung was
betrifft
unsere Wirtschaft was betrifft unsere
Politik was betrifft unsere
Gesetze was betrifft
unsere
Richter sehr viel Sachen das ist unsere
Hausaufgabe was müssen wir aufführen
weil ich führen mit Hilfe von unserer
Partner und wir brauchen gemeinsame eine
Karte zu machen gemeinsame Plan zu
machen Schritt bei Schritt der in Europa
zu integrieren weil wir sind geografisch
wir sind Europäer mit unserem
intellilität wir sind Europäer mit
unserer Geschichte wir sind Europäer
aber wir müssen wir brauchen europäische
Lebensqualität und ohne Reformen ohne
auch Hilfe von unserer Partner die
Reformen zu machen brauchen wir auch
Unterstützung deswegen
meine Mama macht gemeinsam müssen wir
das machen das ist unsere Aufgabe das
ist wichtig auch wichtige Aufgabe haben
wir schon viel gemacht und haben wir
noch viel zu machen also Korruption ist
noch ein Problem aber sie sehen sich auf
einem Weg ähm
was betrifft was betrifft meiner Arbeit
wir machen alles mit unserer Partner das
Korruption zu besiegen wegen
für Arbeit Transparenz ist sehr sehr
wichtige Mittel gegen Korruption und
deswegen
von Anfang an was betrifft keyf wir
machen alles
Transparenz was betrifft
Land was betrifft Wirtschaft wir
arbeiten zusammen mit SAP machen wir
transparente Budget Ava Stadt wo alle
ankommen Ausgaben ist alles transparent
wir haben schon sehr viel gemacht und
trotzdem machen wir müssen ja noch sehr
viel machen denken wir nochmal auf den
Jahrestag was erwarten sie von Russland
wird es diese Großoffensive geben
erwarten Sie auch Angriffe noch mal
vermehrt auf Tier wie bereiten Sie sich
vor
es kann gegangen ist
Hauptstadt
Kiew ist Herz
durch eine
sehr Putin
erlebt sehr viele Symbole und Kief war
vor vielen vielen Jahren die Hauptstadt
von der ganzen Russland und von unserer
Religion und
bleibt ein Ziel von Moskau von russische
Regierung
deswegen
wenn die haben
Gelegenheit die Möglichkeit
die auf jeden Fall werden Kiefern
greifen aber wir sind starke Zement aber
schließlich nicht aus ist möglich ist
möglich deswegen wir müssen vorbereitet
sein das heißt wenn er auf Symbolik
sitzt dann ist dann setzt dann ist
natürlich auch dieser Jahrestag sehr
symbolisch
Jahrestag ist auch sehr symbolisch und
deswegen ich schließe ihn nicht raus die
Putin Versuch kann auch versuchen
greifen was heißt das für die Arbeit
eines Bürgermeisters von Kiel
riesige Herausforderung von morgens bis
zum abends weil wir sind für
verantwortlich für Service für Strom
Wasser
sind für Heizung für
transportation für medizinische
Behandlung für Ausbildung
die Weine die größte Stadt in Osteuropa
ja
4 Millionen Anwohner und
deswegen
vier Millionen Einwohner ohne Strom
heizungs-katastrophe wählen und deswegen
das ist nonstop 24 Stunden 7 Tage pro
Woche ist Arbeit sehr viel
sehr viele Herausforderung aber alles im
Griff
und ich möchte eine sagen
und deswegen
die Sicherheit ist eine die wichtigste
Faktor für jede Ukraine und unsere
Bürger und
kiefen sich ihre Hände und wir
geben alles was können wir für
Sicherheit und schutzen jedes Leben
jedes Familie jede unsere probieren wir
noch einmal kurz über diesen
symbolischen Jahrestag hinaus wie
glauben sie wird es weitergehen in
diesem Krieg
ich bin keine wahrsage und
Prognose zu geben ich bin fest überzeugt
wie gewinnende Krieg
wenn haben wir eine
Koalition von alledemokratische Ländern
der Welt
gegen die Krieg
wir sind zu Hause und wir haben alles zu
verlieren und deswegen die kämpfen für
überleben wie gewinnen und wir hoffen in
dieses Jahr 2023
Wunsch vor jeder unserer Bürger die
Frieden kommt in dieses Jahr wieder in
unseres Land
aber trotzdem kann ich nicht sagen wie
lange das Kind dauert
meine Prognose
bekämpfen
meine Prognose hoffen wir drücken wir
Daumen machen wir alles was es möglich
von unsere
Krieg zu werden
aber leider
sehr viele von diejenige was hat Krieg
angefangen
er kann jede Sekunde kriegen
wer sie zum Moskau durch seinen Namen
kennt jeder
und wir hoffen wir hoffen und machen wir
alles und hoffentlich die ich hoffen die
Krieg wird trotzdem dieses Jahr werden
und
mit eurer Unterstützung mit deutscher
Schlüssel von Deutschland mit
Unterstützung von europäischen Länder
mit Unterstützung von
Vereinigten Staaten
wir sind viel stärker und unsere Wunsch
ein Teil von europäische Familie so
werden unsere Wunsch einen NATO-Mitglied
weil nitrale Status das war gesehen
heute das war eine Fälle für uns
beginnt dafür gibt es von meiner
persönlichen
eine klare Regel
ohne Krieg
gibt keinen Sieg
gehen wir für unsere Familie
für unsere Städte kämpfen für unsere
Land für unsere Zukunft wünsche ich
Ihnen alles Gute und ich hoffe wir sehen
nicht zum zweiten Jahrestag wieder